BEEN CONFIRMED BY THE COUPLE.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN RELEASED HIS
$1.5 TRILLION BUDGET PROPOSAL.
IT INCLUDES AN 8% INCREASE ON
AGENCY OPERATING BUDGETS, AND IN
THE OVAL OFFICE FRIDAY THE
PRESIDENT SAYS HE HOPES IT WILL
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
SENATE REPUBLICANS CRITICIZED
THE LESS THAN 2% INCREASE IN
DEFENSE SPENDING.
THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT INCLUDE
THE PRESIDENT'S $2 TRILLION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE.
HERE TO DISCUSS WHAT THAT --
WHERE THAT PLAN STANDS AND THE
ROAD AHEAD IS CBS NEWS BUSINESS
ANALYST JILL SCHLESINGER.
JILL, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, GIVE US THE BASICS
OF THIS PROPOSED INFRASTRUCTURE
PLAN.
>> Reporter: IT BASICALLY IS IN
FOUR BUCKETS.
THE FIRST IS WHAT I WOULD CALL
CLASSIC INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THAT'S ROADS, RAILS, TRANSIT
SYSTEMS, ABOUT $620 BILLION.
ANOTHER $650 BILLION FOR MAYBE
WHAT I MIGHT CALL THE -- THE
HOME ECONOMY.
BR
BROADBAND, BETTER PIPES AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THE THIRD ASPECT, LET'S CALL IT
THE WORKPLACE ECONOMY, RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPMENT, THERE'S MONEY
FOR MANUFACTURING, SMALL
BUSINESSES, ABOUT $580 BILLION
FOR THAT.
AND THEN $400 BILLION IN A
BUCKET OF SPENDING FOR THOSE
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO HELPED
THE ELDERLY AND THE DISABLED.
>> JILL, THAT BUCKET, THE
CAREGIVING BUCKET, SEEMS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'RE
USED TO.
WHAT'S THE RATIONALE FOR THAT?
>> Reporter: WELL, THE HAGZRATIE
IS SOMETHING CALLED HUMAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I HAD TO LOOK THIS UP MYSELF.
BASICALLY IT REFERS TO SPENDING
BY THE GOVERNMENT FOR EDUCATION,
FOR THE GENERAL HEALTH AND
WELFARE OF THE POPULATION.
THE FIRST TIME IT WAS ACTUALLY
USED WAS AFTER WORLD WAR II WHEN
WE HAD THE G.I. BILL WHERE A
BUNCH OF VETERANS WERE VERY
HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO GET LOW-COST
MORTGAGES, FREE EDUCATION, AND
VA HOSPITALS.
SO IT'S THE INFRASTRUCTURE, BUT
THE HUMAN INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> AND AS WE KNOW, THE G.I. BILL
HELPED TO FUEL THE MIDDLE CLASS.
BIG QUESTION HERE FOR A LOT OF
FOLKS BOTH DEMOCRAT AND
REPUBLICANS -- HOW DO WE FUND
IT?
AND WHAT IS THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN?
>> Reporter: THE BASIC PREMISE
OF FUNDING IS THAT CORPORATE
AMERICA HAS REALLY DONE
INCREDIBLY WELL OVER THE LAST
30, 40, 50 YEARS, AND ESPECIALLY
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS, AND
THAT IT IS CORPORATE AMERICA
THAT WILL FOOT THE BILL FOR
THIS.
THE FIRST WAY TO DO THAT IS
THROUGH THE ACTUAL CORPORATE TAX
CODE, AND REMEMBER THAT BEFORE
WE HAD THE 2017 TAX CHANGES, WE
HAD CORPORATIONS PAYING A TOP
RATE OF 35%.
THAT WENT DOWN TO 21%.
THE BIDEN PLAN WILL ACTUALLY
INCREASE CORPORATE TAXES TO 28%.
SO SORT OF SPLITTING THE
DIFFERENCE.
AND THEN THERE'S A NUMBER OF
WAYS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD CUT DOWN ON LOOPHOLES.
THERE WOULD BE AN EFFORT TO HAVE
A GLOBAL MINIMUM TAX RATE.
THAT IS TO PREVENT A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM WHERE COUNTRIES LOWER
THEIR TAX RATES TO BRING
COMPANIES TO THEM, AND A MINIMUM
TAX FOR U.S. COMPANIES AS WELL
AS U.S. COMPANIES PAYING A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THEIR BIG
MONEY PROFITS AND HAVE THAT
TAXED AT A 15% RATE.
SO ALL CORPORATE AMERICA NOT